Ah forse
[Musica]
Ma si muovono anche a vedere ah ah
la prigione di Wilson Eccola là Hobby
spaventoso Oggi dovremmo scappare da una
nuova prigione siamo uno scheletro lui e
non lo so È tipo fatto di metallo di
metallo
e cose strane termosifoni Sì sembrano
quasi fuori questo lo vedi Vabbè
invitare un po' di fantasia strana
Comunque oggi nuovissima prigione
Mettetevi comodi prendo lasciate un bel
mi piace e iniziamo subito questa nuova
Escape Room Scegli una difficoltà
normale o difficile ovviamente svegliavo
normale Eccolo vedi il termosifone qua
sotto Eccoci qua confusione tra me e
vitale Eh è un'altra personaggio vediamo
come questo nuovo Prigioniero
del cibo in scatola qui sono gli
spaghetti in scatola Uh sono fagioli
veramente Ah i fagioli Buoni sono
iscritto i fagioli ti mettono le ali ah
ah i fagioli erano una bugia Eh
non lo so qualcuno è stato in questa
prigione è un po' impazzito Secondo me
ma vediamo cos'altro c'è qua mese Guarda
stavano contando i mesi credo che siano
stati in questa prigione per molto tempo
c'è anche scritto sono sempre lì a
guardarci chi ci gua' Ci osservano
sempre le guardie credo questo è un
bagno un gabinetto e qua c'è la carta
igienica e i cucchiaini
forse hanno scavato il tunnel del piede
qua c'è il lavandino intasato sa chi è
stato qua dentro che crimine avrà
commesso però scappa qua dentro Aiuto
c'è scritto scappa scappa io scappa
scappa me ne vado vado ciao ciao ciao
ciao rimanete qui dentro esploriamo bene
questo qui Insomma c'è un'altra Cella
vedi solo che qua c'è un lavandino vuoto
e non c'è il materasso forse chi ha
fatto il crimine qua è stato peggiore
sei stato più cattivo qua no aspetta
aspetta la porta aperta di prigione Dove
sono i miei fagioli ah ah ah
Ah c'avevo li dirà Ehi Ehi senti i
fagioli Qualcuno li ha messi nell'altra
cella non credo che riuscirei arrivarci
perché sei chiuso qua Ok scappiamo
adesso guarda guarda guarda poi nella
sua camera c'è scritto là nel muro c'è
scritto C'è un cuore e poi c'è scritto
Beans viene i fagioli sono i fagioli in
inglese quindi lui è proprio ambito
lavorativo
ci sono anche dei quadri con i fagioli
ho preso una cella mi piacciono proprio
tanto i fagioli eh Mi dispiace per te ma
i fagioli sono nell'altra cella non ci
arriverai mai mi dispiace Addio c'è
scritto scappa c'è corri qua e poi dice
veloce veloce dobbiamo correre veloce
attenta c'è qualcuno dietro di noi
Guarda vedi Guardala
che ha preso Ah ha preso anche me ma
perché hanno messo una guardia di
metallo Sì dobbiamo scappare eh Che cosa
c'è qui dentro ragazzi c'era una sedia
elettrica in quella cella ho scoperto un
altro personaggio più avanti è qui e che
personaggio sembra un cuoco lo vedi Eh
no non sto cercando qui guarda Eccolo lo
vedi
il tempo a vederlo Ok non devo distrarmi
Devo andare avanti anche se ci sono le
registrazioni del cuoco non so che non
devo cercare di non essere preso dalla
guardia Mister Winston Uh qua Questi
sono dei mostri quelli lì dietro eh Poi
cos'altro c'è Ah
Ve lo ricordate c'erano i personaggi i
cattivi delle altre Hobby che abbiamo
fatto
il dentista cattivo e poi quella è vero
quindi il creatore di queste Escape Room
questa prigione sicuramente è lo stesso
delle altre del dentista cattivo di
quelle altre Qual era quella coi denti
forse era il pasticcere non mi ricordo
mi sa che era proprio il dentista erano
Erano i mostri del dentista che ci
inseguivano Qua c'è un carro armato ma
costa 1.000 robot eh Eh
ma chi ha mille robebox in ogni Escape
Room c'è sempre tipo I sotterranei le
foglie Oh perché non hai fatto questi
sono tipo di tutte le Escape Room Allora
secondo me dobbiamo premere questo
pulsante qui che dice potenza uh wow ok
Vediamo cosa succede Uh sono apparsi
sono apparsi dei cittadini tipo dei
gradini sospesi nel vuoto
Non funziona
così
effetto speciale pappa pappa
Secondo me siamo nei sotterranei della
prigione Qua dice il reset Ripristina i
Puntelli Ah ah ah no no non ho capito Eh
forse quando continuiamo il pulsante
scompaiono le punte Qua bisogna prendere
questi barili e poi piazzarli da qualche
parte per poter salire io vedo Vitale
con le braccia ma davanti ma non hai
nessun Barile non è quello nessun Barile
stai prendendo tutti i per il fantastico
Sì sono i brividi finti Vediamo se io ci
riesco allora Ah sì ma diventano
trasparenti
Non ho capito dove li stai mettendo Eh
uno sopra l'altro Ah per salire là sopra
figo vediamo
quasi è un po' difficile bisogna creare
proprio delle scale vola ce l'ho fatta
Forse ce l'ho fatta anch'io Vediamo
Ma come fai poi a salire sui barili
per fare un passetto alla volta ce l'ho
fatta Brava ok no no no no non cadere
non cadere Okay
Riprendi le stringhe Io provo a saltare
uno due trans
sembra si muova però sembra contento ce
l'ho fatta non ci credo ce l'ho fatta
sono elegantissimo Vedremo chi uscirà
prima della partita Aspetta aspetta è
estremamente pericoloso sopra c'è un
numero cosa potrebbe essere 4-83633
proviamo a indovinare prima di entrare
cosa potrebbe essere estremamente
pericoloso i cavi elettrici che fanno
con la scossa elettrica
No io penso a dei mostri Guardate come
dice la sorella che ti mangia invece tu
pensi ti ricordi quelle del numero
esatto
No vabbè vabbè Avevi ragione ma avevi
ragione c'erano
tre quattro mostri orribili Ah Ah Ah
guarda che forse te li sei immaginare
perché qua c'è solo una macchinetta tipo
pesce 400 dopo che scendi li vedrai
Guarda vedi non ci vado io non mi
ricordo Erano bruttissimi facevamo
troppa paura Guarda veramente Allora io
rimango qua perché questa stanza
bellissima Allora dobbiamo superare Dai
sbrigati materassi Che bello io avete
dato una stanza tutta tipo con i
materassi oppure con il lettino
gonfiabili in cui puoi saltare tutto il
giorno
Muoviti Ma chi l'ha detto che
dai scendi Uffa
Quand'è che siamo ad Halloween però non
voglio vedere i mostri Ahmed ah ah hai
visto Te l'ho detto che è brutto eh si
sono dimenticati qualche pixels
ti volevo solo dire che è un labirinto e
io mi perdonare i labirinti Mi dispiace
è rimasta solo la mia testa Comunque è
rimasto solo la tua testa mi ha fatto
mille pezzi Allora prima da che parte
sono andato proviamo a mandare qua a
destra poi Oh io ho trovato delle frecce
Forse sto andando dalla strada andando
Eh beh forse sto andando nella parte
giusta ho trovato un sacco di frecce io
ho deciso di seguire
io seguo questo giocatore Perché in
genere ragazzi sono più bravi di noi non
sono schiappe come noi
finora non mi sta inseguendo nessun
mostro Oh non ci credo sono sono
riuscito da solo 12 sono riuscito
come hai fatto Hai seguito qualcosa
Uh Qua c'è un personaggio che
ci sono anche i personaggi fantasmi che
scompaiono io con la super velocità
invece mi sono spiattellato su un muro e
son caduto
Wow
salvato da quel mostro fatto dai
Pixelmon di fretta proviamo fretta Oh
facciamo una gara arriva prima prima che
finisca la super velocità Quindi non
finisce prima questo stage 3 2 1 via
sono in testa Mi dispiace basta così
interessante Guarda che io sono più
davanti Eh mi sono sfracellato perché
cioè no così Qualcosa mi dice che
vincerò io questa Challenge
Non mi portare sfigata perché io ho
quasi finito Sì
almeno un pochetto Oh vediamo quanto
costa l'elicottero l'elicottero Sì certo
davanti alla mamma basta Sì vabbè ciao
questo creatori dei giochi di robots
mettete qualcosa Grazie ogni tanto
magari loro un elicottero che ne so una
forchetta
Oppure non lo so fate
vi pagare quei robot magari no
lasciate un mi piace se questo video
raggiunge i 5000 mi piace nella prossima
Escape Room completo Harry Potter vero
la prima il primo oggetto
che lo comprerò anche su costerà tanti
robusto quindi lasciate un bel mi piace
qua sotto e ricordatevi di vedere i
prossimi video per vedere che oggetto
comprerò Qua c'è una cella Aspetta
guarda quasi quasi ho deciso di
ritornare indietro perché perché perché
no perché Perché avanti c'è un po' di
cose che fanno paura un'altra volta più
di uno Vabbè io volevo salvare qualcuno
da questa ce l'abbiamo fatta Eh qua ci
vogliono infilzare in queste punte
Oh no Poverino questo giocatore si è
sfracellato davanti a me e qua c'è
un'altra cella solo con un letto Forse
sono loro tutti riuscite a scappare per
Ragionieri di questa prigione vista
almeno io sono non è molto bravo Oh no
forse sono proprio questi qua che sono
qua dietro Li ha trasformati chi Eh
adesso sono arrivato vedrai lo scoprirai
ho invitato tutte le trappole Ah magari
sono proprio questi
facciamo andare Gli altri giocatori come
funziona e questo giocatore si è fermato
e sta aspettando noi sta usando il
nostro stesso trucchetto cioè aspettare
che gli altri vedono a sfracellarsi per
distrarre i nemici si muovono quindi noi
dobbiamo stare fermi vedi sono molto
inquietati come muovono la testa adesso
che cosa bisogna fare ehm bisogna
aspettare che muovono la testa sì e poi
dopo quando stanno fermi là
sono dei mostri di metallo
indietro però là sopra c'è un'altra
scritta andiamo subito a vedere cosa c'è
scritto stavo scherzando
Ok Chi sarà stato a mettere queste
scritte non puoi e poi c'è scritto noob
Che vuol dire tipo schiappa in inglese
bene In effetti siamo un po' Skipper
Uh Qua c'è un jet per volare nelle sei
proprio queste tre Ci hai trovato una
roba robot cosme Insomma Uffa
super vantaggio invece se volete fare i
salti e fare tutti gli oggetti Vediamo
se evitare cadrà adesso già avantissimo
sto salendo sopra cosa ci sarà uhm uhm
là sopra Wow Chissà se dovremo
affrontare Mister Wheels sono alla fine
sicuramente eh Anita ti dico
praticamente queste qui
C'è mancato poco Sì brava si muovono
troppo concentrato non riuscivo a
parlare come sta andando Anita Ti prego
a passare probabilmente ci riuscirò
anche
cosa sta succedendo
perché girano le streghe le stringhe
Veramente sto parlando come Google
Translate di giochi perché girano Questa
croce
velocissimo uh uh brava ce l'hai fatta e
vediamo dove siamo nelle fogne Siamo in
un tubo Uh uh uh
rotoliamo giù Ok adesso dove siamo
finiti
Ma ti devi nascondere
dove mi nascondo questi buchi li vedi
vediamo sicuramente Ehi c'è qualcuno qua
Vai Vai Guarda devi nasconderti
vai adesso Vai vai Vai forza
[Musica]
tu non sei stato spiaccicato neanche una
volta perché sono bravissimi
sfracellarmi no che c'è sono ritor
nato
Ma come ma noi stavamo provando a
scappare dalla lavatrice
però devo dire che sono bellissimi
questi vestiti Oh alla fine del video
scrivete un voto da 1 a 10 a queste
Escape Room Anche noi vi diremo il
nostro voto una volta che la finiamo e
soprattutto dobbiamo prendere il badge
ma Anita Come Ah ok Io mi ero spaventato
qui per questa ragnatela ma in realtà
era molto facile Sì era tipo finta Oh
non devi dire che si rompo
meraviglioso Mi hai fatto cadere Eh sì è
vero Sì Hehehe provo senza avvitare in
mezzo ai piedi uhm uhm uhm uhm uhm
eliminato 0 di 30 e sono sono un bazooka
mi dice che questa è la sfida finale
aiuto aiuto aiuto!ahahaha
Ok andiamo a prenderlo subito Ehi
guardaticcio eliminati 3 e poi comunque
è entrato 0 adesso quelli che abbiamo
eliminato no Sì ma poi quando prendi il
bazooka si resetta Questi siamo in tanti
altri
ma devo comunque
ma è troppo difficile
Non puoi scappare devi eliminarli solo
13 sono riuscito a prenderne Eh Wow io
sono tre poi hai visto ci sono di tanti
colori verde blu Wow Ma soprattutto
massima concentrazione Ah forse bisogna
prima scendere da qui dove sono abbiamo
perso la porta No perché ti inseguono Oh
Ottima idea Brava brava
non escono da lì escono Perché l'altra
volta mi hanno spiaccicato
bloccato nel muro l'avete visto vediamo
se riesco a eliminarne il più possibile
da qua oh che brutti quelli verdi che
strisciano io non capisco non Stanno
uscendo i mostri per me però ne ho
eliminati 13 di 30 eh C'è qualche banco
forse Wow se sei qua nella porta è molto
più facile eliminarli Ne ho eliminate
già 14 come devo fare Ehm devo andare
Eccolo qua e ogni tanto arriva ah
voi siete Mostri ci sono quasi ne ho
eliminato 19 non ci credo quelli che
strisciano sono i più paurosi
dai ragazzi forse ci riusciamo a vincere
25 anni 30 ma sei bravissimo eh Solo
perché ho trovato questo trucchetto
ah ah
ah no l'ho preso proprio alla fine
quelli che strisciano
più veloci sono più veloci
Hai vinto
però riprovo con la mia tecnica Sì
secondo me qualche è facile anche tu
stai provando così
però ne ho presi solo 8 io Beccatevi
questo ma perché alcuni arrivano più
belle è più facile Però da qui
effettivamente anche se non riesco a
prenderlo
Ehi ma che succede ogni tanto si bugga
Sì ogni tanto si bugga non escono più
Beh meglio e non lo so perché poi dopo
deve far ricominciare da zero Oh
maledetti
mancano ancora tanti Sì sono troppi Però
perché mi hanno messo così tanti sempre
più finiti dai Forse stiamo andando bene
che cosa sta succedendo me ne mancano
solo quattro Non ci credo tu stai per
vincere o forse non lo so Vitale
prendere il peggiore
Non ci credo Hai vinto sono riuscito a
sbloccare l'altro livello
cioè non lo so si è aperto una porta Dai
dai dai Ce la devi fare il badge Uffa Ti
aspetto qui Ok ci proverò Ah okay ti
aiuterei volentieri ma non li vedo i
mostri Eh sì perché purtroppo le devo
eliminare 30 e io da sola
girati dall'altra parte brava brava Che
brutte quelle che strisciano
indietro torna indietro torna indietro
cosa ti prendono dai vai vai
cliccati vai
dai dai dai dai dai
te ne mancano ancora un sacco Hahaha
dai 20 21
forse ce la faccio forse ce la faccio 22
brava
Che brutto
Quanti ne mancano Non lo so Ho paura a
guardare non mi voglio spostare da qua
Questo vicino
ce l'hai fatta non ci credo non mi sono
neanche resa conto che ne ho eliminato
o ci sarà ancora una sfida sappiamo sul
treno Silvia
qualcuno deve guidare però no aspetta
come si fa a guidare qui Premi qualcosa
Uh uh uh Hai visto che bravo cosa vuoi
fare anche il treno
io ho ancora il lanciafiamme Eh vediamo
Semmai Eh ma attenzione siamo tipo su
una montagna che cosa sta succedendo
ah ah
Wow continuazione ho preso il peggio Oh
ci sono io il gigante Ehi aspetta un
momento Dov'è il Belgio Grazie ragazzi
per aver giocato Dov'è il Belgio Oh me
l'ha dato il peggio è uscito scritto qui
a fianco
Ah ho capito forse devo entrare qua
dentro vediamo proviamo a entrare qua
no che succede è un'altra è un'altra
skate Room un pagliaccio pappa è ottima
per Halloween proviamola subito e poi
sceglierete la vostra preferita intanto
mi avete scritto che
la vostra paura più grande sono i
pagliacci Infatti nello scorso video vi
ho chiesto cosa si fa più paura quindi
Vediamo Ah adoro adoro adoro gli episodi
di Halloween scappiamo prima della
prigione e poi dal pagliaccio
bellissimo dobbiamo correre tipo tempo
di divertimento dice ok Google vediamo
cosa c'è scritto comunque di
divertimento
Io mi sono precipitato giù dal coso non
so dove sono arrivato è tutto nero tutto
buio ma che
cosa devo fare
paurosa
stai più vicino Ok va bene ma perché sto
camminando nel vuoto Ah no è solo perché
è nero forse
è molto strano finora eh
Sì così rimandi certo
lui l'ha preso no
eh terrificante Anche secondo me è il
pagliaccio quello più brutto di tutti
cioè il più pauroso il più paurosi dei
fantasmi adesso forse ho capito Non
bisogna mai girarsi indietro bisogna
sempre andare avanti
non lo vedo finora
cioè c'è qualcosa
qua aiuto
Ok è rimasto là dentro Speriamo di
essere Salvi eh aiuto Sei riuscita a
passare qui da queste trappole
gigantesche
Ma dobbiamo camminare sul filo delle
bandierine Eh sì Uh qualcuno è caduto
giù L'ho visto Però devo dire che
l'ambientazione di queste Skip è molto
bella perché sembra di essere tipo però
è anche molto paurosa Eh sì hai paura
rosa per il pagliaccio guarda lo vedi là
il fatto Oh Oh che paura che cosa c'è lì
non abbiamo dato il voto da 1 a 10 che
però uno di prima io ti do uno otto in
mezzo perché secondo me era molto
divertente tu davvero nove perché mi
sono divertito un sacco e soprattutto
perché ho preso il badge ah ah scrivete
nei commenti il vostro voto e poi daremo
il voto anche a questa Anche se finora
mi piace un sacco
paurosato A proposito di cose paurose
visto che siamo in tema cose paurose
praticamente Halloween avete già letto
il mio libro storie paurose a scuola di
misteri se non l'avete letto questo il
periodo migliore per leggerlo anche
perché potrete accumulare i punti
coraggiosi
Anche se ancora non ce l'avete e lo
trovate in ogni libreria o su Amazon e
qua ci sono dei quadri Bianchi Che cosa
significa Oh Che figo c'è un gioco
fantastico qui Ah tu sei già andato
avanti Non vedo l'ora guarda di godermi
lo spettacolo quando tu sbaglierai a
fare questi tiri Hahaha Magari
sbaglierai tu dai Ciao Anita dove siamo
allora devi prendere quelle palle da
baseball da basket
perché io ho una Mira Terribile
come palleggia è troppo carino provaci
Uffa dai
Eh
ma io ho cliccato lì Ma scusa come
faccio a Miranda vai a tirare una palla
dall'altra parte
eh Ce l'hai fatta Bravo Luca Bravo bravo
era terribile che cosa c'è qui c'è
scritto nuota no no no no
no no no no no non c'è altro modo no no
no no no no no no Aiuto fa Dobbiamo per
forza buttarci qua dobbiamo capire dove
porta questa cosa vediamo se riesco a
scappare da qua no mi sa che l'unico
modo è entrare là dentro Forse ho capito
e va bene c'è una lampadina qua sotto ma
non so che cosa serva sto notando Spero
che non arrivi adesso il pagliaccio
certo
credo di aver visto la freccia Non lo so
dov'è il bottone il bottone ma al buio è
impossibile
Oh no E ora e cerchiamo questa bottone
Eccolo qua
stronzo Eh purtroppo non posso provarlo
per te io non so non so come si ruota il
Roblox
Ok ho premuto il bottone si è aperto il
cancello Si è riuscita a passare Sì
credo che ora forse
finiremo da un'altra parte faremo liberi
non lo so sì ho trovato sono riuscito
come hai fatto aiutami Siamo fuori dal
parco divertimenti del pagliaccio c'è
anche una ruota Wow È bellissimo Forse
riesco a vederla Aspetta dai devi
prendere il bottone e poi andare tutto
avanti trova il bottone sono riuscito a
leggere trovo il bottone dove sarà il
bottone bottone sono salvata per un
momento io invece sono qua dove c'è c'è
c'è della lava Questa è stata il
pagliaccio sicuramente il parco
divertimenti con la lava Uhm
fa paurissima quello brutto cioè sta
aspettando che io cada per
ti ha mangiato Sì infatti Vitale è
arrivato incastrato
ancora nuotando sta cercando l'uscita
Cerca gli oggetti da immontare Che vuol
dire riproduzione
Forse da montare Ah sì devo fare la
strada come prima
devo salire là sopra
perfetto
sei riuscita già a salire No devo
prenderne ancora altri e poi salgo nella
ruota panoramica
Ma scusa è un momento forse dovevi
saltare dritta No credo di aver
sbagliato credo che devo prendere queste
scatole e metterle qua è vero c'è anche
scritto Ok ragazzi guardate che
bellissima scultura moderna che ho fatto
Ora vediamo se riesco a salirci sopra
sono rimasto io a nuotare No devi salire
qua sopra questa mappa ce l'ho fatta
Davvero ce l'ho fatta e ora devo
scegliere
devo solo panoramica
No è bellissimo Guardate
Wow che bello ma è gigante è un parco
gioco gigante tipo sì È troppo bella
questa Escape Room pagliaccio assassino
e lì c'è un trenino dovrò andare lì
Quelle sono le montagne russe Secondo me
Pagliaccio ti vuole mettere lì e fai
fare finta Fammi volare da qualche parte
piano piano piano non devo cadere non
devo cadere adesso Oh brava Che figo
raga ma le montagne russe Vai vai uh uh
uh
bellissimo
Peccato che sono qua da sola
e ora non mi dire che mi fa volare da
qua oh credo che paura fighissimo Ma sei
ritornata di nuovo nelle fognature
Non lo so dove siamo Ehi Ma questo era
all'inizio del gioco
Falsomiele all'inizio Guarda laggiù c'è
il pagliaccio lo vedi più di uno sarà la
fine delle Escape Room Non lo so vediamo
devi devi saltarci sopra e cercare di
non farti prendere quando a terra
salta salta ho capito Devo evitarle
piano piano
OK riproviamo più piano più piano Non
voglio essere presente quando sei così
vicina No ho paura che settaggi No
aspetta Santissimo
così è vero non riescono a prenderti
proviamo con la tecnica di Vitale
Scommetto che non ci riesco No così no
no no Aiuto aiuto Fammi vedere dove
metti i piedi se salti a caso Ok
riprendi
Posso provare io ok Ora provo a Vitale
intanto Vitale il personaggio di vitale
è rimasto ancora lì nuotando cercando
quando sei qua vicino salti vedi così
piano piano un salto alla volta Uhm che
brutti poi secondo me si può andare
anche di qua ah ah
facile e ora questa parte verde dovrò
evitarla o no Lo sai che non lo so forse
è la super velocità e la super velocità
torna indietro a prenderla
Pronti Via
oh oh oh oh oh
velocissimo c'erano dei denti e la bocca
del pagliaccio come funziona qui non
capisco Ah no ci sono anche i pagliacci
guardatissimi sembrava
proprio super fortuna Uh è difficile
questa Escape Room salta Speriamo di non
dover affrontare il posto
[Musica]
ci sono delle risate di sottofondo
una sorta di insetto Ok
brutto Che brutto
Che brutto brutto
Questo video è diventato un Prova a non
aver paura del pagliaccio ah
OK riproviamo questa volta non mi giro
così non mi farò vedere ho paura non mi
farò paura scappa perché va così il
letto questo personaggio di Rocco Eh ma
non corre
Eh lo so che sia passeggiando è un
personaggio Cioè non che un pagliaccio
malefico la sta inseguendo questo
corridoio non voglio guardare dietro non
voglio guardare dietro sento che è
vicino il pagliaccio non voglio guardare
Voglio guardare Vai Vai prova adesso sì
sì sì sì ok attenta Attenta Dove metti i
piedi eh C'è qualcuno lì eh eh eh
succede che sta succedendo
ragazzi
devo colpire i ragazzi
Wow
Dai che ci sei quasi Sì sì Va beh
insomma guarda quanti ce n'è solo
guardati le spalle eh
via quella bruttissima il più brutto
Sembra un ragno
sei più bello
che brutti che brutti che brutti
sono tutti quanti eliminati vedete ne
mancano tre tipo al massimo quattro uno
due tre oh oh ce l'ho fatta credo Vabbè
Eh ora Eh adesso Prendi questa
macchinina a forma di trenino Vai Pronti
Via No questa è la montagna russa
Ma mmm ma magari con una trappola magari
una trappola
Non lo so giro della morte e poi ci
siamo Bye bye Anita nel gioco Ah ma
perché
Che figo te l'ho detto che Oh no
ho preso il badge ci sono io giganti
addosso m'ha ferito
perché hai preso due badge questa volta
Bravissima dopo otto nove perché mi è
piaciuto un sacco perché super paurosa
voi che avete dato 6 perché sono rimasto
incastrata da 200 non riuscivo più a
nuotare ah ah
su quella che preferite eh buona